- [Narrator] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
- Good evening, everyone.
I'm Jennifer Wolch.
I'm dean of the college
of environmental design
here at Berkeley.
And it's my great honor and pleasure
to welcome you to the
2015 Hitchcock Lecture
by the preeminent architectural critic,
educator, and writer, Paul Goldberger.
For those of you who may
not have been here yesterday
when Paul gave his first Hitchcock lecture
the Charles M. and
Martha Hitchcock lectures
were endowed in 1885
with the first lecture starting
on the Berkeley campus in 1909.
And then in 1932, through a bequest
from the Hitchcock's daughter,
Lillie Hitchcock Coit,
the program was expanded.
I think if you look at the
list of Hitchcock lecturers
it's almost impossible
to overstate the eminence
of the people who have
been Hitchcock lecturers.
This elite list primarily includes,
especially in the early years, scientists.
And right after the series started
there were a number of years
focused on earthquakes.
But I guess we can understand
why if it started in 1909.
The coterie of luminaries includes people
like Robert Oppenheimer
and Stephen Hawking,
just to name a couple.
And then also historians
and social scientists
are prominent on this list.
Wassily Leontief, Clifford Garrets,
Noam Chomsky, Herbert Simon,
Kenneth Boulding, Amart Yat-sen.
It was not until 1952 that
an architect or urbanist
came to give a Hitchcock lecture
when Joseph Hudnut, who
was the dean at Columbia,
and was the first dean of
the Harvard Graduate School
of Design, came to Berkeley.
And I must say that
the Hitchcock committee
really made him work.
He gave seven lectures.
So you're getting off really light, Paul.
He gave three on Paris in the middle ages,
one entitled, "The
Common Man in the City,"
and another entitled,
"We Are Building a City."
And then he did one on
the Golden Gate Bridge.
It suggests that despite
his east coast origins
he was not entirely immune
to the charms of the city by the bay.
The next architect and scholar to come
and give a Hitchcock lecture
was Ada Louise Huxtable,
the Pulitzer prize-winning
architectural critic
for the New York Times as well
as the Wall Street Journal
and a prolific writer.
And in 1982 she gave two
lectures, both on tall buildings,
"The Tall Building Beyond Function,"
and then, "The Tall
Building Beyond Style,"
which later became a book about
tall buildings reconsidered.
And then the last person
to come before Paul
was Berkeley's own Peter
Hall, Sir Peter Hall,
who taught for many
years in the department
of city and regional planning.
And he came back to give
Hitchcock lectures in 1990
and spoke about, "Cities and civilization:
"Culture and Innovation and Urban Order."
And also his second lecture
was, "The End of the City:
"The Report of My Death
Was An Exaggeration."
So he was calling into question
the thematics of the time
which seemed to imagine that the city
maybe was on its last legs, not so fast.
Well, this afternoon the
Berkeley Hitchcock committee,
as well as the college
of environmental design,
our faculty, our students, and our alumni,
are incredibly proud to
welcome Paul Goldberger
to our campus and our community.
And to be able to have
the distinct experience
and benefit of hearing
his lecture this evening.
And also during the day to be able
to interact with him on
a more informal basis.
So what I'd like to do now
is turn the podium over
to associate professor
of architecture and urban
design, Nicholas de Monchaux,
who will introduce Paul.
Nicholas.
(applause)
- Hi.
My name is Nicholas de Monchaux.
And it is my great pleasure
to introduce Paul Goldberger
to you this afternoon.
And in so doing I also have to apologize
for breaking what must be
one of the cardinal rules
of these introductions, which
is talking about myself,
albeit very briefly.
The relevant fact here
being that my twin brother,
Thomas, like Paul, makes his living,
albeit as a less distinguished
architecture critic,
which in turns relates to the reasons
why I am not an architecture critic,
which is that it is too hard.
And not just for the obvious reasons
to do with today's shifting
landscape of media.
But hard for a much
more longstanding reason
which has to do with
the nature of the critic
and the nature of the
architectural profession itself.
So much of our current contemporary
consciousness of design
as a culture is thanks to
the increasingly instrumental
and influential role of design
in shaping our changing personal
relationship to technology.
From this, of course, is born a new
and proliferating kind
of design criticism,
endlessly parsing interface
and logic of consumer devices,
Apple's chief amongst them.
But architecture's great difficulty
is everything to do with
its profound difference
from such consumed objects
which is why the architecture critic
must play a much more profound role.
Unlike Apple Watches,
the very powerful people
who pay for buildings
are more often than not, not
those who have to use them,
or live with them.
And the architects who design them
have actually highly variable ability
to control either the largest
or most detailed
components of their design
and can rarely risk
offending those for whom
they might build, as
it's said, in the future.
And the legacy of this imperfect mix
of causation and responsibility becomes
the collective landscape
of the city and its ecology
with which we all must live for far longer
than a building's circumstances
of origin hold true.
Into this landscape steps
the architecture critic
who must alternately befriend an enemy
to client, architect, and public alike,
standing up for and recognizing
quality in not just design
but also patronage and public ethics.
And also noting, where
necessary, its absence.
This is a mine field and
few have negotiated it
so successfully as our guest tonight.
Paul Goldberger's career
began at the New York Times
where his criticism earned him,
in 1984, the Pulitzer Prize.
There are many, many other
awards which I will not list
because I've talked too long already.
His career continued at The New Yorker
and most recently to his role
as contributing editor at Vanity Fair.
Throughout his career,
Goldberger has tirelessly acted
as advocate, observer, public
proxy, and cultural curator
across these many
constituencies and actors
who bring together the
contemporary city into being.
And not just in New York but
across the folds and contours
of what is increasingly
becoming a global conversation
about the city as well.
Now of course as well
as teaching the public
through his writing he
has also had a career
as a leader and educator in the academy
that would, on its own,
put many of us to shame
as David Parsons, and now
the Joseph Urban Chair
in design and architecture
at The New School.
To me, however, Goldberger's
particular achievement
has been to extend the
short and singular nature
of the classic critics column
into a more extended
trenchant observations
in the form of many, many books.
Unlike the works of lots of critics,
these are not compendia,
but extended intellectual
and erudite observations
not just on the shape of the city
but also on the forces shaping it.
From the early prescient, "On The Rise,"
to the timely, "Up From Zero,"
to 2009's, "Why Architecture Matters,"
to his most recent forthcoming
biography of Frank Gehry,
Goldberger's career and intellect
continue to point towards
the fundamental role of the critic
yet with a depth and eloquence
that few critics accomplish.
Which is to say,
they distinguish between
success and excellence,
they make legible what is inscrutable,
they judge what is wanting,
but above all, they extend,
in patron, public, and designer equally,
our sense of what is
possible and even necessary
for architecture to accomplish.
Please join me in
welcoming Paul Goldberger
here this afternoon.
(applause)
- Thank you so much, Dean Wolch,
and Professor de Monchaux.
Those incredibly generous words,
actually they remind me of something
that Linden Johnson said
when he received an
equally kind introduction,
which was how sorry he
was that his parents
were not here to hear it.
His father because he would
have been amused by it
and his mother because she
would have believed it.
I feel very much the same. Thank you.
Yesterday I said a word
or two at the beginning
about how honored I am to
be part of the extraordinary
legacy of the Hitchcock series.
I said that not aware that Joseph Hudnut
had delivered two and a half
times the number of lectures
that I'm doing.
My only hope is that he didn't
attend as many classes and studios
so that at least we even out that way.
Yesterday in the first
part of what I suppose
could be considered an
investigation into the
current challenges facing the city
I talked about what I
called the generic city.
And while all was not doom and gloom,
the point of the talk was, I
will be the first to admit,
a little bit downbeat.
The forces of technology,
for all the good they are
doing us in so many ways,
are also powerfully speeding
up the homogenization
of culture that has been a
force in the world for some time
and which seems now to be unstoppable.
How cities can retain, let alone create,
a distinct identity when
there is little incentive,
other than tourism, to
look and feel different
is an enormous challenge.
Today I want to talk about
the other side of the coin,
the more positive aspect of
cities as they are evolving
in the information and technology culture,
which is the growing belief that cities,
which since time immemorial
have been incubators for creative ideas,
a history that no one has
tracked more thoroughly
and with more erudition
than Sir Peter Hall,
that they are still where
creative people seek to be.
Not everyone, of course,
believes this to be true.
I recall reading a dialogue between
the management guru Tom Peters
and the writer George
Gilder in Forbes Magazine
on whether technology would mean
an end to cities as we know them
or would give them a continued future.
Gilder saw no point to the old city,
which he saw only as a tired
relic of the industrial age.
He celebrated the way in
which electronic communication
was rapidly making it,
in his view, obsolete.
You no longer have to
be there, Gilder argued,
so why would you want to?
It's dark, dirty, noisy, and crowded.
Talk to everyone by email
and look out your window at trees.
Much nicer, right?
Peters, like Sir Peter Hall
and his Hitchcock lecture
it seemed took a more measured
and ultimately wiser view,
pointing out that, as he put it,
"There is a fundamental human
dimension of real contact
"that cannot happen on the internet
"and which real cities
were designed to facilitate
"and still do."
"The richness, the
exuberant variety of cities,
"is the fount of economic creativity
"and business growth," Peters said.
I agree with Peters
but I think it's obvious that
the nature of the city is changing
even if it is not, as Gilder
predicted, becoming obsolete.
The city is not economically necessary
in the way that it once was.
Markets can function without it.
No matter how much we may love cities,
we cannot pretend that they are necessary
for the transaction of business,
or the movement of
capital, as they once were.
As the sociologist Saskia
Sassen has written,
"The computerized workplace
can be located anywhere.
"In a clerical factory in the Bahamas
"or at a home in the suburbs.
"The growth of information
industries has made it possible
"for outputs to be transmitted
"around the globe instantaneously.
"The globalization of economic
activity suggests that place,
"particularly the kind of
place represented by cities,
"no longer matters."
But Sassen went on to point out
that this is not, in
fact, what has happened.
There's a paradox.
The very forces that were
supposed to eliminate the city
have turned out to make
at least some cities
more important than ever.
National and global markets,
as well as globally integrated operations,
require central places where the work
of globalization gets done.
She points out, certain cities,
New York, London, Hong Kong,
Los Angeles, Tokyo, Sydney,
Sao Paolo, Frankfurt, to
name some of the major ones,
are nodes in an international system
that has made them critically
important around the world
and has even given them a kind of identity
that is distinct from that of the nations
of which they are a part.
They are global cities,
more connected in many ways to each other
than to the geographical
regions that surround them.
So we can say that if cities are not
economically necessary in
the way that they were,
they are economically
necessary in a different way,
a way that has only been
enhanced, not diminished,
by the technology of the 21st century.
I think we could say that
in another way as well.
Which is to say that cities
are more entrenched in our culture
than they were, say, 50 years ago.
They're more culturally
necessary than ever.
And we can see that in the greater energy
that is now present in
the downtown centers
of cities that come nowhere near
belonging in the class of
global financial centers.
There's more going on
in Boston, and Chicago,
and Charlotte, and Austin than
there was a few years ago,
even though those cities don't qualify
as belonging in the class of
mega international financial
centers that transcend their
own geographical regions.
By talking about the city as
culturally necessary today,
I mean something much more
than that they are needed
as places in which culture
is housed or consumed.
Cities do provide a
home for culture death.
But I'm not talking about the fact
that they are where the
ballet, or the opera,
or the art museum, choose to locate.
I mean culture in the broadest sense.
Culture as meaning our
ethos, our civilization,
how we define ourselves.
I think that cities
feed the culture today.
The idea of urbanism is, itself,
for many people a cultural experience.
The fact of being in the
city is now, for many people,
as satisfying and broadening
a cultural experience
as going to the theater or an art museum.
A younger generation engages with
the city in a different way.
And I think a more participatory way
than their predecessors.
It is not afraid of the city
since it knows primarily a city
that is safe and prosperous,
if less diverse than it once was.
And for all kinds of reasons
the generation under 40 is
less inclined to see the city
only as a place to work,
as their parents or
grandparents might have,
and see it instead as a place
in which to live and to play.
If, that is, they can afford it.
I will come back to
this point in a moment.
The increasing economic
inequalities of the city,
the way in which the city,
by making so many things
visible and manifest
before our very eyes, inevitably
places the national problem
of income inequality in
especially high relief.
For now, however, let's observe
only that, as I just said,
San Francisco, and Boston, and Chicago,
and Austin, and Pittsburgh, and Denver,
and even, astonishingly, Detroit,
not to mention global cities
like New York and London,
possess a level of vibrancy
that is far greater than
even a few years ago
and in complete conflict
with what the anti-urbanists,
anti-urban theorists predicted.
But Richard Florida's theory
that the renewal of
cities is fueled by a new,
so-called creative class of young people
misses the point, I think.
The glib phrase "creative class"
has now entered the language
but it does not explain everything.
I think there are a lot of things
behind the renewal of cities
and the presence of the
so-called creative class
is not a cause but is more
in the line of an effect
of the enormous rise in the
financial services industry.
We may not believe that our movement
away from industrial economy
and toward a financial services economy
has always been a positive
thing for society.
But it is impossible to
deny that it accounts
for at least as much, if
not more, urban growth
than the eagerness of
younger, more creative people
to be in urban areas.
The reality is that what has
been called a creative class,
the creative class, is far
from entirely creative.
A young analyst working on Wall Street
wants to live in the city
and partake of a certain kind of life.
That she does is good
for society, I believe.
Better than if she had
retreated to the suburbs.
But does it make her creative?
Perhaps it is fair to say that
this economic and social class
is more receptive to
creativity than their parent's
or grandparent's generations were
and that's the difference.
They are more sophisticated.
They like better food.
They are at ease with technology.
They are not suspicious of
modern art or modern furniture.
It is surely not that
they are all artists.
There are not enough poets, and writers,
and painters, and dancers, and actors,
to fill all of these
new condominium towers
in cities all around the globe.
And if there were, 99%
of those creative people
wouldn't be able to afford them.
There is a marketplace for creativity
or a desire to be in an environment
that embraces creativity.
That is certainly the case today
in cities around the world.
Again, if you define the creative class
as the market for creativity
as opposed to people doing the creating
then the notion of the creative class
as behind the urban revival
may make some sense.
But if you take the phrase literally
to mean the people designing, writing,
painting, acting, and so forth,
well, there are a lot of them, yes,
but not nearly enough to
fuel the urban revival
that we have been experiencing
in many cities in the last two decades.
So the ubiquitous creative class label
flatters the consumers of creativity
by equating them with the creators.
Either that, or it naively
assumes that the world we live in
so believes in creativity
that it compensates film
makers, and artists,
and teachers, and dancers,
the way it compensates
financial analysts and bankers.
And if you believe that,
well, I have a bridge
to sell you in Brooklyn.
Nothing, of course, could
be farther from the truth.
In fact, things are moving
in the other direction
toward less equality of income, not more.
And many of the truly creative people,
the artists, and writers,
and actors, and filmmakers,
have been priced out
of the creative cities
that by Richard Florida's measure
belong to them and that
they have helped to revive.
What young writer now can afford
to live in New York or San Francisco?
Yesterday I talked of beginning
my own career in New York
in the economically depressed 1970s,
which turned out to be
a weirdly great gift
to me and my family.
It allowed me to raise
children in the city
in a way that as a journalist and academic
I could almost surely
not have afforded to do.
Those days, as we've said, are long gone.
In San Francisco as much as New York,
where the neighborhoods you
once were afraid to walk in
you now can't afford.
I was in London last week
and it is exactly the same thing.
The pace of gentrification
has so accelerated
that we seem almost to be skipping over
the point of equilibrium
where a neighborhood is a diverse mixture
of older residents,
new arrivals who bring a
different kind of sophistication,
families, creative people,
and a smattering of business folk.
Instead the process of
gentrification seems
less a benign engine of gradual upgrade
than a bulldozer that figuratively
and sometimes also literally
seems to crush what is in its path.
And it hardly helps, of course,
that technology has upended the market
for much creative work,
especially in the fields
of writing and music
where the pie is now vastly smaller,
meaning creative people
have less, not more,
money at their disposal
even as they try to cope
in this new hyper-inflated market.
What I experienced in
New York in the 1970s,
when good real estate was accessible
to professional people at
a wider range of income,
and hence, and this is the
really important thing,
at a wider range of types of profession,
is no longer to be found there,
or in San Francisco, or
Boston, or Los Angeles,
where urban housing seems
increasingly out of the grasp
of all but the most highly compensated
of the younger generation.
In New York, that means finance mostly,
with a smattering of tech.
In San Francisco, it means tech mostly,
with a smattering of finance.
But this is a distinction
without a difference.
To buy urban real estate cheaply
you now have to go to Detroit,
where many of the truly creative
who now cannot afford
even to live in Brooklyn
move west to set themselves up
in an affordable urban environment.
This is another example of creative people
with limited resources
jumping in to take advantage
of a disadvantaged economy
and in so doing, help to turn it around.
It is profoundly exciting
to see this happening.
And the resurgence of
Detroit as a creative center
is pleasing in every way.
But it should not, I think,
be considered a true revival of the city.
As pleasing, even heartwarming,
as the creative resurgence of Detroit is,
there will never be enough to it
to equal the jobs that have been lost
and to bring the city back
to the place it once was.
Yes, the arts are critical
to the urban economy
but more from the standpoint
of consumption than creativity.
And consumption in the visual arts
means tourists coming
to Metropolitan Museum
where the marketplace of the art auctions
at Sotheby's and Christie's.
It does not mean the creative act itself.
I doubt that Detroit will
ever again have the muscle,
economically, to be a
major consumer of culture.
It is great that it is filling
up with young creative people
who have been displaced from Brooklyn
by the vast army of
financial services workers
who now seek to live in
so-called creative environments.
But it is hard for me to see
how this alone will turn Detroit around.
Detroit's revival, and
let's put that in quotes,
is fine such as it is.
But if it cannot be directly connected
to a broader kind of economic growth
I'm not sure what it will ever amount to.
And I say that being
aware of the noble effort
of a company like Shinola,
which you may have heard of,
which is committed to bringing
manufacturing back to Detroit
and makes watches,
bicycles, and leather goods
of decent quality, and then
markets the hell out of them
with a brilliant advertising campaign
that encourages those of us
with a commitment to urban revival
to believe that we are helping this effort
by buying a $500 quartz watch
that has been assembled in Detroit.
Although not in fact literally made there
because the movement is
imported from Switzerland.
I will say while we're on that subject
that I'm of two minds about Shinola,
which positions itself as an
earnest, scrappy manufacturer
determined to swim
upstream against the tide
but which is actually
a division of a huge,
private congolmerate
called Bedrock Brands,
the same company that owns Fossil Watches
and which has based its
entire marketing plan
on the notion that there are enough people
who think the idea of something
made in Detroit is now cool
so that they will spend $500
on a $100 watch with
a handsome retro face.
Shinola spent millions of
dollars on a retail outlet
in Tribeca, in Lower Manhattan,
which has been so successful
it reportedly met its
first year sales goal
within the first month.
Affluent young professionals
apparently love the idea of
buying something made in Detroit
so long as it is not a car, I suppose,
which I'm sure they believe
still needs to be made in
Munich or Stuttgart to be valid.
But jobs are jobs.
And Shinola does keep a lot
of people busy in Detroit
assembling these things,
and that is all to the good,
even if it is not the
true, earnest startup
it so brilliantly
advertises itself as being.
And if this is marketing
as much as reality,
I do think there is something
significant to the fact that
you can market the idea
of made in Detroit.
That people, whoever they
are, and wherever they are,
will want to buy it.
That would not have
happened a few years ago.
Even Chrysler, as you may have seen,
has tried to market the same idea
and at one point tried
an advertising campaign
that referred to its cars
as imported from Detroit.
Clever, although I don't
think it made much difference
or led anyone to replace
their BMW with a Chrysler.
That slogan morphed
into "America's import,"
much more vague, even slightly ambiguous.
And it should be noted,
minus the mention of Detroit.
If sophisticated young
watch buyers and cyclists
find the idea of made
in Detroit to be cool,
the far bigger market of
automobile buyers does not.
Chrysler's inability to duplicate
the Shinola marketing idea
shows us, I think, that this
is all a kind of niche market
and reminds us, as I said a moment ago,
that whatever it is that
is happening in Detroit
and however good it is,
it is far too marginal to the economy
to truly turn around an entire large city.
In reality, most manufacturing takes place
far away from cities now.
Some of it takes place far away
from our entire country,
from our continent,
and as we all know, has moved to Asia.
Much of the industrial manufacturing
that does still happen in
the US is in the south,
where labor and other costs are lower
and governments fall all over themselves
to offer corporations
incentives to open factories.
The questionable wisdom of that
is a subject for another day.
For now, let's say only
that it is unlikely
that manufacturing will
return on a large scale
to any large, established
city in this country,
or elsewhere in the world,
and that cities need to find
another basis for their economy
as they move forward.
The vast growth of the financial
services, legal services,
media, healthcare, and
educational industry,
and they are all industry,
suggest that these things
will be the city's salvation,
since so much employment in these fields
is concentrated in urban areas.
It's a reasonable assumption
and I'm not here today
to say that it is wrong.
But I do worry nevertheless
that the evolution of our
cities into service centers
staffed by upscale professionals,
clean and appealing though it may be,
is also a reminder that
many of the elements
we all like in our cities today
exist at the pleasure of these groups,
not to serve a broader
range of the population.
These professional sectors,
we can think of them as being
the very consumers of culture
I was referring to a
couple of minutes ago,
like to concentrate
themselves in urban areas
but they do not do that because
they truly have to be there
but because they like the aura
of culture and urban activity.
They seem to be rejecting
the world of the suburbs
with its dependency on the automobile
and its elevation of private
space above the public realm.
They seem to favor the urban culture
and the stimulation it brings.
This is a good thing.
It would be absurd to
argue that it is not.
But, and there is always a but,
the city does not exist solely for them.
And that is another paradox
of our urban life today
that the new economy of technology
and international finance
requires an underside of low
paying jobs to sustain it.
The cleaners, and the
cooks, and the bakers,
and the drivers, and the chambermaids,
and the nannies, and so forth.
And that these people are paid
at the very lowest end of the scale,
meaning that there is
more and more disparity
between incomes in the new
city of the 21st century.
The immigrants who toil beneath
the glittery surface of the new city
and struggle to survive in
it are often hardly visible,
in part because they almost invariably
cannot afford to live anywhere
near the glamorous center.
And that center, in many cities,
for all its life and bright, upbeat,
don't we love the city energy,
is, as urban cultures go, a bit too easy,
a bit too homogenous, a bit too defined
by this young urban professional class
and by its even richer cousin,
the international global rich,
who invest in condominiums
all over the place
and fly from New York,
to Abu Dhabi, to London,
to Hong Kong, and Sao
Paolo, and back again,
keeping the real estate markets hot
but using cities less as true places
than as concrete versions
of safe deposit boxes,
places in which to safely stash cash.
The real estate market
in many cities today
is a product less of local needs
than of international
economics, of currency markets,
and the need for cash to have
an occasional place to rest
as it washes across the globe.
That is not necessarily
the healthiest basis
on which to build a city.
I would like to believe that
the major buildings in our skylines
exist as something other than
pure investment vehicles.
Though buildings have always existed
partially for that reason
it has rarely been their
sole reason for being
as it so often seems to be today
when so many new buildings
seem to be physical embodiments
of the movements of global capital
that the cities themselves represent.
The demand that so many
condominium towers fulfill,
especially in New York and Hong Kong,
but also in Vancouver, and San Francisco,
and London, and Shanghai, and Moscow,
is not the demand for places to live
but the demand for places in
which to invest excess cash.
Many of these places, as you surely know,
are barely occupied.
And while these buildings
now dominate the skyline,
in New York, the very
latest 432 Park Avenue
is taller than the Empire State Building.
So I am not talking
about trivial structures
that we can ignore.
While these buildings
dominate the skyline,
their occupants surely do
not populate the sidewalks.
They add surprisingly little
to the ongoing life of the city.
Once their owners have enriched
the building's developers
by purchasing their
apartments for vast sums,
they seem to do little else with them.
Jonathan Miller, a prominent
New York real estate appraiser
put it best when he
called these apartments
safe deposit boxes in the sky.
Places where people put their valuables
and then rarely visit.
The city of such buildings
is not the city we aspire to.
And it is surely not the creative city.
It is booming economically but
is it healthy economically?
By now we should know, I think,
that these two are not the same thing.
I think we've already seen
that for all the short term good
there is in rising real estate values,
too much wealth is making
our cities less diverse
and that it can sometimes
make them less energetic,
not more energetic,
less the kind of places
in which real creativity is inspired.
The city of zillion dollar
condos isn't making culture
anymore than it is making
automobiles or anything else.
It is just consuming it.
And it isn't even doing very much of that
because its occupants aren't
there most of the time.
I'm not entirely sure
what we can do about this
because no city, no matter how
determined its leaders may be
can control economic forces
that are increasingly not local,
or even national, but global.
But we can be more aggressive, I think,
in seeking to limit the extent to which
pure investment vehicles
dominate the skyline
and squeeze out the very urban life
that they claim, often
disingenuously, to be reinforcing.
For a time, I used to worry
that the destiny of our cities
was not to be derelict places
that no one wanted to visit
as we feared a generation ago
but places that everyone wants to visit
but no one has to be in
because they no longer
have an essential purpose.
That in this age of urban infatuation,
we are at risk of developing
21st century versions
of Venice or Amsterdam.
Wonderful, glorious places
that exist mainly for
people to stroll around in
and comment on how wonderful
and glorious they are.
Now, that is better than the
South Bronx of the 1970s,
of course, but that's not the point.
The point is that we want the city
to be more than just
entertaining, but necessary.
I don't want the city to be a theme park,
fun to walk around in when
you need to take a break,
but not a place where real
life and real work take place.
I do feel that even so
many of the good things
we celebrate in cities today,
the sheer joy of walking around,
the pleasures of shopping,
the exhilaration of people watching
and the visual variety that
always brings surprise.
Even these things can
sometimes encourage us
to think of the city only
as a thing for entertainment
and thus make us dance on
the edge of the theme park.
In the theme park, we only
consume, we never create.
We look and we are entertained.
We are safely away from
the stresses, and tensions,
and forces by which things are made,
the clashes and pressures
out of which culture
and ideas come.
As Charles Moore pointed out 50 years ago
in his classic essay, "You Have
to Pay For The Public Life,"
which foresaw all of this,
Disneyland's popularity came in part
because it satisfied the urban impulse,
an impulse otherwise absent
in Southern California.
It satisfied that urban impulse
in a safe and contained way.
Now, the theme park, of course,
is supposed to be without challenge.
And that is fine if we're on a playground.
But the real city was never
supposed to be without challenge.
It ought to be at least
a little bit difficult,
at least a little bit dirty,
at least a little bit messy.
The city we celebrate today
often strikes me as too clean,
too neat, too packaged,
too managed, too easy.
If we think that kind of city,
the city of shopping and entertainment,
is a place out of which great culture
and great creativity will come
I fear that we will be sadly mistaken.
Now all of that said,
I don't want to fall into
the trap of believing
that there ever was an ideal urban era,
where creativity flowed
and the forces of capital and of culture
were in perfect equilibrium.
It is useful, I think,
to look back at Paris
in the mid 19th century,
a time that we are
accustomed to thinking of
as an era of great urban life,
as a time when whatever the
complex political picture
of Europe may have been,
there was at least an urban culture
that flourished and triumphed
over both politics and capital.
Well, think again.
In fact, Paris' golden age,
which did, in so many ways,
define our sense of what
an urban place should be,
was also a time of incredible
struggle over modernity,
and real estate development,
and tension between
financial power and the arts.
Baron Haussmann, charged by the
emperor with updating Paris,
which, in many ways, in the
middle of the 19th century
was still a rather medieval city,
cut through great boulevards
and engaged in ambitious public works,
and in so doing, defined the
Paris we know and love today.
But he also threw neighborhoods,
indeed the entire pattern
of the city, into turmoil.
Progress was seen by most people then
as the enemy of culture,
as a set of forces that
were selling out the city
to moneyed interests.
And there seemed to be little room
for artists, shopkeepers, craftspeople.
Indeed, for workers of any kind.
Let me quote, for a moment,
from TJ Clark's great study
of 19th century Paris,
"The Painting of Modern Life,"
in which he writes that, and I quote,
"In place of the crumbling houses
"where the tailors and the
coppersmiths had lived,
"the builders of boulevards,
avid to recoup their costs,
"had put up lavish blocks of apartments
"with stone moldings,
and ironwork balconies,
"and running water.
"The rent of such places
were impossibly steep
"and the rents of the
rest of the neighborhood
"Followed them upwards."
By Haussmann's own estimate,
rents in the center of the city doubled
between 1851 and 1857.
And they went on climbing thereafter.
The working class began to complain.
It was argued that in place of one Paris,
Haussmann has made two.
The accusation was linked
with the issue of high rents
and the plight of those who had lost
a place to live in the city.
Haussmann, the critics said,
had built the Boulevard Malesherbes
as a kind of thoroughfare for speculation.
He had laid out the inhumane
avenues around the toile.
This was the city of
courtesans and bull markets.
Here was ostentation, not luxury,
frippery, not fashion,
consumption, not trade.
Observers agreed that
in some important sense
the city was more inflexibly classed
and divided than ever before.
That one was entering the age of the
residential district and
the industrial suburb.
You don't have to dig deep
to find an echo of this today
in contemporary San Francisco,
where the pressure to make the city work
for the needs of tech companies
has led to equally bitter
battles over displacement
and long public debates as to
who the city is actually for.
But there's something
else that's going on here
and it gets us right to
the heart of the role
of the city as a so-called
creative environment.
And that is the relationship
between San Francisco
and the world of Silicon
Valley to our south,
where it can sometimes
feel as if we are coming
to have something akin to
the residential district
and industrial suburb
that TJ Clark observed
in Paris in Haussmann's time.
Of course, Silicon Valley is
no normal industrial suburb.
It is where more wealth has been created
than anywhere in the world
and where a form of creativity,
creativity in technology,
flourishes even amid urban
sprawl, and as I said yesterday,
a far more conventional suburban landscape
than anyone there wants to admit.
So if we fast forward from
Paris to our own time,
which is the real model for a place
that inspires creativity today?
The example of Silicon Valley
that suggests that traditional
cities are obsolete
in an age of mass communication?
Or that of ever more prosperous
and luxurious San Francisco?
Actually, for that same
comparison I could have used
the evidence of Silicon Alley,
as people have been
calling Lower Manhattan,
which now has a huge concentration
of tech businesses itself.
But I'll come back to that in a moment.
Here in the Bay Area,
what I find remarkable
is how many young workers
in the tech industry today
have no desire to live in the valley,
even if they work there.
They prefer to live in San Francisco,
to be like the rich Parisians
who segregated themselves
in Haussmann's luxurious city.
Although in this case they are different
from the rich Parisians who
never had to dirty their hands
by going to the industrial neighborhoods
since the young workers
in the tech industry
are the very people powering
the workforces of Silicon Valley.
This, of course, is why
all of the major companies in the valley
now operate huge fleets
of private luxury buses
that shuttle back and forth
between San Francisco and the valley,
sparing these privileged
employees the unpleasantness
of a commute along the crowded freeway.
As all of you who live here probably know,
the buses are sleek, enormous,
and unmarked except for
electronic lettering
over the windshield
indicating which neighborhood
in San Francisco the bus is bound for.
Mission, Noe Valley, Castro, Potrero Hill.
Most of them are white.
The Apple buses, not
surprisingly, are silver.
They carry bicycles, and
it goes without saying
that they're Wi-Fi equipped.
When an employee gets on
the Apple, or Facebook,
or Google bus in the morning,
he or she is considered to be at work.
Google alone transports upwards
of 3,000 employees a
day on its bus service
which is now so extensive it ranks among
the larger public transportation systems
in the state of California.
The buses have become a
necessity for Silicon Valley,
not because they expand
the work day modestly,
but because it was the
only way they could attract
and retain workers who might otherwise
have balked at the 40 mile commute.
A 28 year old living in Noe Valley
is more likely to be willing to spend time
in a luxurious bus with Wi-Fi
than to want to sit behind
the wheel of a car on 101,
or to make his way to
downtown San Francisco
to take a commuter train
that will deposit him
at a station that is still likely to be
several miles from where he works.
Big intercity buses have become
the travel system of choice,
so much so that Craigslist
ads for apartments
now carry lines like,
"Genentech, Apple, and
Google buses within a block,"
which signals a location
that is a lot more meaningful
to potential tenants
than proximity to the
public transit system.
Let me talk for a moment
about the growing preference
of younger workers to live in the city
since it represents a vast shift
in the culture of the tech industry
and its effect is only
beginning to be understood.
Silicon Valley grew up
around a certain university.
I don't remember what it's called.
University of Paolo Alto or
something like that, I think.
Which until a few years
ago seemed to have only
the most tenuous relationship
to San Francisco.
The law firms and venture capital firms
that emerged around the tech industry
located along Sand Hill
Road in Menlo Park,
in quarters that were
posher than the startups
but every bit as suburban.
The Rosewood Sand Hill, the luxury hotel,
whose restaurant is to the tech industry
what Michael's in New York
is to the media industry
is a sprawling low rise resort
that looks as if it could be
in a prosperous midwestern suburb
but for the slight overlay of buzz
that fills the dining room
and the fact that the parking lot
has more BMWs and Audis,
not to mention Teslas,
than you would find in Kansas City.
If you were a venture capitalist
or corporate executive in that industry
you were likely to live
in Atherton or Woodside.
If you were a young software engineer,
you lived in a garden apartment
in Mountain View or Cupertino.
And other than big events like
Macworld Expo and the like,
much of Silicon Valley acted as if
San Francisco were as
distant as Los Angeles.
The high cost and limited availability
of housing in the Silicon Valley towns
may have had something to do
with the gradual shift
towards San Francisco.
But it's not as though housing
were either plentiful or
cheap in San Francisco either,
which of course, as all of you know,
has long been one of the most
expensive cities in the country.
What is really fueling it
is the much larger trend
that we've been talking about
of younger professionals expressing
a preference for urban living
even after they start families.
If the simplistic
phrase, "creative class,"
does not explain everything
about the resurgence
of older urban neighborhoods
all across the country,
it does connect to why a 30
year old video game designer
would now rather live in San
Francisco than Mountain View,
whatever the commute.
At this point, the tech
companies' bus services
are not just a convenience.
They're an essential recruiting tool
for the valley's major employers.
A piece of infrastructure on
which the massive exercise
in reverse commuting that has come
to define Silicon Valley depends.
The connection between Silicon Valley
and San Francisco seems to be deepening
all the time, in unexpected ways.
It's no longer a case
of city versus suburb.
If anything, their traditional
roles have been reversed,
since the valley, with
its big tech companies,
now represent the region's
main economic engine
while the city acts as the
place of entertainment,
relaxation, socializing, and sleep.
The journalist and blogger Ken Lane
wrote not long ago in the
online journal The Awl,
"San Francisco, with its leafy parks,
"and charming roadhouses,
and distinct villages,
"and restaurants,
"and commuters fleeing
every morning to work
"is the Brooklyn to an as
yet unbuilt Manhattan."
Again it is the 19th century
Paris that Haussmann created.
This city/suburb inversion is fascinating
because it suggests that the city,
to some extent, has already
become the magnetic artifact
that exists to give pleasure,
not to be a potent creative force.
The valley's richest entrepreneurs
have always seen San Francisco that way.
Some of them bought houses
in Pacific Heights years ago,
and some of the city's posh
districts, as weekend getaways,
starting the inverted
pattern of looking at
Silicon Valley's suburban landscape
as the messy, work-oriented place
you wanted to get away from
and the city as the pleasanter
place to which you escaped.
But the torrent of 20 and 30 somethings
wanting to live in San
Francisco full time now
is a much more recent development
with its implications far broader
than a few dozen billionaires
buying fancy houses in Pacific Heights.
It says a lot more about
how cities aren't essential
as the kind of marketplaces
they once were,
when you needed the city
as a place to do business.
You can do business
anywhere, as we've said,
and as the success of
Silicon Valley proves.
But the things the city does offer,
a lively, diverse environment
full of visual stimulation, culture,
food, and all kinds of people,
is exactly what suburbs can't provide,
even when they get as rich and successful
as the ones in Silicon Valley.
Kenneth Lane further said
in that article in The Awl,
"As disappointed visitors
and new employees discover,
"Silicon Valley is a
dull and ugly landscape
"or low rise stucco office parks
"and immense traffic-clogged boulevards.
"The fancy restaurants are in strip malls.
"There is nothing to do. Nowhere to go."
That's surely why more and more startups
and small to medium-sized companies
are locating in San Francisco
instead of Silicon Valley.
When I wrote about that phenomenon
last year for Vanity Fair,
it was clear that the city itself
had become the most
powerful recruiting tool
a lot of companies could ask for.
The younger people want to be in the city,
a veteran of Google who now manages
public relations for Twitter told me.
And if you follow the news across the bay
with any degree of attention,
you know the story of Twitter,
which has been based in San Francisco
since it was founded in 2007,
and which, when it decided
it needed new space,
took over three floors in a vast,
empty, art modern building,
originally a furniture mart,
on a seedy section of Market Street
not far from the San Francisco city hall.
From the reaction in the neighborhood
you would have thought it was Google
and not Twitter that arrived in 2011,
since within a few months of
the company's announcement,
construction started on
two condominium towers
on nearby sites.
The rest of the old furniture mart
was rented to other tenants.
And some nearby buildings
went into renovation.
Twitter had kissed the neighborhood
and it went from being a frog to a prince
inside of a few months.
This has been controversial,
as you probably also know,
since the rocket speed gentrification
of this part of the city has been,
to use the tech industry's
favorite word, disruptive.
What it is disrupting, of course,
is not other technology, but people.
People who can no longer
afford to live there
because their neighborhood is like a rug
that has been pulled out from under them
in what has seemed like an instant.
This is all too reminiscent
of Haussmann's remaking of Paris,
and it is not good for the
diversity that the city needs.
But I am inclined to feel
that it is ultimately
worth it for the survival of the city
because the coming of
much of the tech industry
to San Francisco has also revived
the city as a creative center
and made it a place of work.
That's important for reasons that
go far beyond the politician's
desire for tax receipts.
Job creation holds the city back
from the fate of sliding
into the beautiful,
alluring irrelevance of Venice,
or the equally beautiful and profound
but no longer creatively
essential city, Amsterdam.
Now I can see that there's a certain irony
in saying that the tech explosion
keeps San Francisco real
since I know that gaining this reality,
the reality of having a
vibrant, creative economy,
is coming at the cost of another reality
which is the reality of diversity.
That is increasingly the fate
of the creative city today.
It is a struggle, a constant struggle,
to balance a meaningful
and productive economy
against the roughness, the grittiness,
the complexity, the diversity,
of the city as its best.
In the case of San Francisco,
there is one particular benefit,
or maybe we can say rationalization,
which is that the most
powerful economic forces,
those of the tech industry,
are, by and large, creative forces,
or at least partially creative forces.
The game designers and
the software designers
are not poets, and actors, and painters
who need to work as waiters
while they wait to make some scant money
from the arts that they
are passionate about.
Here the creative people are
part of the economic engine
and that makes a tremendous
amount of difference.
We could say the same for
the slice of New York,
what is called Silicon Alley,
since so many tech firms
have located there as well.
And Google now has more
employees in Manhattan
than anywhere in the world
other than its headquarters
in Mountain View.
That said, the creative
tech industry in New York
is still overwhelmed by the
financial services industry
which is still the economic bellwether.
If you put these two things together,
the huge financial services industry,
and the growing presence
of a tech industry,
you have a gargantuan market
for culture in New York.
The largest in the nation,
and perhaps the world.
And one that also includes
another realm besides technology
that is often mistakenly overlooked
when people talk about
creativity in the city,
which is the world of fashion design.
But still, when you
put all of it together,
you have an overwhelmingly
large market of people there
who consume culture
and want to live in a
so-called creative environment,
only a very few of whom are
actually creating culture.
This puts the cost of the city
out of reach of almost
every artist, architect,
writer, dancer, musician,
film maker, and actor.
And that is not getting any better.
Where do these people go?
For a while, as we said, it was Brooklyn.
And now that Brooklyn too
has become so expensive,
some of them, as I said a few minutes ago,
are going to Detroit.
Before we despair,
let's keep in mind that the
universe of urban neighborhoods
was once a lot smaller
and that Brooklyn was a very
different place 40 years ago.
We can all make jokes about
the artisanal food culture
of Williamsburg, and the furniture makers,
and fancy bars, and boutique hotels,
but it is not, for the
larger life of the city,
such a bad thing.
And Williamsburg, like so
much of the rest of Brooklyn,
not to mention Jersey City,
and Hoboken across the river,
and Harlem, and Manhattan,
are better places than they were.
It is the fate of creative people in part
to find new places and to settle in them
and begin a process of change
that, in time, the mainstream adopts.
We saw it in SoHo in New York,
the mother of all urban
gentrification, 50 years ago.
As the artists came in and
took over old loft buildings
that had been abandoned by
the manufacturing industries
for which they had been built
but which no longer wanted them.
A neighborhood of intense creative energy
was built within what was one
of the greatest concentrations
of historic architecture
in the United States
and which had been all but ignored before.
It was preserved, and
real estate values rose,
at which point the artists
who made it all possible
could no longer afford to be there.
Now many of them, of course, in time,
no longer wanted to be there
since it had lost so much of its edge
and become, in part, a shrine
to consumerism and chic,
not to creativity.
The edge moved elsewhere.
Now I've just compressed a complex,
decades long history into
a couple of sentences
but it is basically what happened.
And it does show us that
the process of urban growth
and change is one of constant movement.
The edge is always moving elsewhere.
Cities cannot be static.
That, perhaps, is the
most important thing,
that cities are living things
and that for the city to
be a viable environment
for creativity, it has
to change and evolve.
And the change will inevitably
involve its most creative people
because they are almost
always the people on the edge,
and the edge always move.
Creative people see new things
which often means new places.
They are frequently
not only on the edge of
thinking and perceiving,
but on the economic edge,
unable to afford the ever
more expensive center.
But a lot of the time it
is driven by their vision
and their willingness
to go outside of what,
before that time, had been
considered the acceptable bounds
of places to live, as they did in SoHo
and in so many other places.
I realize this can seem like
an excessively romantic view.
I might also be taken as condoning
much of what has happened
in the last generation
that has put our greatest
cities out of reach
of the creative people who
we need most to be in them,
since it the creative
people, the makers of art,
and not just the consumers of it
who keep cities from becoming theme parks,
the places of artifice that
they often threaten to become.
I'm not arguing for complacency here
or suggesting that we do
not need to be proactive
and fight to keep the city more diverse,
both economically and culturally.
We need, as we once did not need,
to continually intervene
to maintain the very things
that the city once created naturally.
Jane Jacobs argued against
planners and politicians
in the '50s and '60s
because every time planners
and politicians intervened,
she pointed out, they destroyed
that natural equilibrium
of good urban neighborhoods
that they considered blighted,
like Greenwich Village.
Today, however, leaving it alone
will no longer give us that diverse,
balanced neighborhood in equilibrium.
It's a paradox but it's an urgent one
that today we must intervene
to maintain what once, in fact,
we needed to refrain from
intervening to protect.
But so while I'm not at all
arguing for complacency,
I'm merely trying to observe
that creativity in the city,
like everything else, is subject
to large, often global, forces,
and that the artist,
as much as the banker,
is inevitably part of a larger system
that is not of his or her making
and which brings both good
and bad things in its wake.
We come back, in the end,
to what makes the city work.
And that is proximity, human contact,
the ability to see each other,
to be reminded at every moment
that we are part of a large
and complex human endeavor
which in the city is not
just a theoretical concept.
It is something we see evidence of
all the time in front of us,
and I believe it affects us profoundly.
The role of the city,
the role of any city,
to put it as bluntly as possible,
is to be a common place,
to be common ground,
and as such, to support
us and to stimulate us.
Lewis Mumford, the greatest
architectural critic of the last century,
gave us a description of the city
that stands in stunning
and eloquent contrast
to the argument that the city is outdated
in our technological age.
"Now," Mumford said, "the
greatest function of the city
"is to permit, indeed
to encourage and incite,
"the greatest possible number of meetings,
"encounters, challenges,
"between all persons, classes, and groups,
"providing, as it were, a stage
"upon which the drama of
social life may be enacted
"with the actors taking
their turns as spectators
"and the spectators as actors."
Notice that Mumford spoke of the city
not only in terms of
meetings and encounters
but also of challenges.
He knew that the city is difficult
and did not attempt to pretend otherwise,
to argue that it is the easiest route.
But he knew that in meeting challenge
there is also a kind of satisfaction
that cannot come from easy routes
and that the challenge the city represents
can, at its best, be ennobling.
And that is what fuels creativity today
as much as it ever has in the past.
Thank you.
(applause)
Thank you. Thank you.
- [Dean Wolch] Thank you so much
for such a stimulating lecture.
We do have time for some questions.
And anyone who would like
to address Mr. Goldberger
should come up right here to the front.
- [Audience Member]
Hi, thank you very much
for two very, very stimulating lectures.
I wonder if I could turn
this around a little bit.
I'm not sure I'm gonna be
able to get this out properly.
One of the things that struck
me from the things you said
is that, in many ways, the
period which we romanticize
as the heyday of the city
was in fact an anomaly.
And I'm thinking of Thomas
Piketty's view of capitalism,
and that the post-war boom, and equality,
and suburbanization were
essentially an anomaly
within the history of market capitalism.
And back to your example
of Belle poque Paris.
I mean, just think of La bohme.
The artists were all starving.
In a funny way,
you seem to be saying, or
it seems to be the case,
that perhaps cities to succeed in the way
we traditionally think of them succeeding
requires substantial income inequality.
Or it's inevitable that cities
will evolve in that direction
which they seem to be doing.
And I'd also like you to comment
on the opposite side of this,
which is the rise and fall of the suburbs,
which is the other side of this.
Which is during that period
where cities were failing,
suburbs were booming.
Now that income inequality has returned,
cities are booming and suburbs
look like they're headed
towards poverty, really, ultimately.
So it's an interesting question.
- It's a very interesting question
and not one easily
answered in a concise way.
I think it's as difficult
to generalize about suburbs
as it is about cities.
Atherton and Woodside
are one kind of suburb
and Richmond is another.
And Berkeley, of course,
has its own rules anyway.
It always has.
And follows no patterns of any kind.
I think many older, closer in suburbs,
are in fact in great difficulty
and are turning out to be, in many ways,
the equivalent of a lot of
older inner city neighborhoods
that have been gentrified
and they're places where
immigrants live now,
often in questionable conditions.
We see that here. We see that
on the east coast, certainly.
A lot of the small towns in Long Island
that are beyond the
rich belt are now places
that have a significantly
immigrant population,
that are almost an
underclass, and so forth.
You ask a profound and
profoundly difficult question
about whether somehow it is necessary
for the ongoing capitalist system
for there to just simply
be economic inequality.
I don't want to sound like an anti-Marxist
but the answer might be yes.
I think that the history
of cities is not one of...
I'm wary of suggesting
an inverse relationship.
Let's put it that way.
I meant by my bringing
up Belle poque Paris
only to say that it
wasn't so easy then either
and that in fact, underneath
that lovely surface,
there were tensions
not nearly as different
as we might think from the
ones we deal with today.
I'm not gonna try to outthink
Thomas Piketty on this issue.
And I'm not an economist, nor
do I wish to pretend to be.
I'm an architecture and urban critic
who is observing certain trends
and trying to see how they connect
to the physical form of cities.
That's only a partial answer, I realize,
but it's ultimately a
question that is itself
a book someone ought to write.
Yes, sir.
- [Audience Member] Hi,
I live in San Francisco.
And I have three questions.
Feel free only to answer one.
The homeless, minimum wage, rent control.
- The homeless, minimum
wage, and rent control.
That's another book.
(laughter)
Rent control I think is a sort of
desperate last ditch attempt
to maintain a viable market--
rather a diverse market
in the face of the enormity
of the forces that we face.
I'm not generally a fan of it.
And I think it is in fact distorting,
significantly distorting to the market.
If the last few years
have taught us anything
it's we cannot trust in the market
to take care of everything.
I will say yet again I'm not an economist.
I know enough to know that
the trickle down theory is not enough.
Distorting and artificial
though rent control may be,
I think it is one of those interventions,
to use a word I used before,
that is probably necessary today
only because of the hugeness
of the forces pushing
in the other direction.
I wish it were otherwise
because I do find it a sort of
a force that in New York, certainly,
has not always been a positive thing.
But now that we see the other side of it
and how troubling it is to see
the city drained of diversity,
I think we have to sort of grant that
it is one of the fingers in the dike.
Homelessness is a catastrophic
issue for our society.
And the fact that it exists at all
in a society of such
extraordinary prosperity right now
is shameful.
And that we do so little.
And certainly nationally that
we do so little about it.
In San Francisco the public
view is far more enlightened
than in most parts of
the country, but even so.
Minimum wage, we are--
I'm the least qualified to answer
because, as I said before,
I'm not an economist.
I'm encouraged by the fact that
several corporations
have sort of preemptively
raised wages in the last few weeks
recognizing that the
extent of income inequality
has now become...
The fact that they are capable
of being embarrassed by
it I think is a good sign.
I don't know ultimately how
much difference it will make.
But it's a good thing that
things like that are happening.
And I think the value of minimum wage
is to create a degree of pressure
that leads other things
like that to happen
more than the wage itself.
But we shall see.
- [Audience Member] Good
afternoon and thank you.
As I was listening I heard you talk about
the tech workers, the tech companies,
some allusions to the
residents in San Francisco
who have been affected by that influx.
But it was only towards the
very end of your remarks
when you referred to interventions
but without referring to city government.
And I wonder what role you see
for city government today
in managing the changes
and challenges that you've described.
And if you could, talk
about, refer to cities
that you think have done
a particularly good job
or a poor job in playing some kind of role
in managing what we're experiencing today.
- That's a very good question.
I did not mean at all to suggest
that there's not a role
for city governments.
In fact, city governments are the most
well positioned to be the agents
of intervention, let's say,
now that we know that some degree
of intervention is necessary.
Cities that have done a
particularly good job.
Well, let me go back to
the part of the question
that involved types of things.
I would like to hope that--
As I said, I am not a
great fan of rent control
even though I concede that it is probably
a useful form of intervention today.
The construction of
more affordable housing,
the requirement of affordable housing,
as connected to market rate housing
and other kinds of profitable developments
is a form of intervention.
We see it in New York. We
see it here in San Francisco.
Which are probably the two
most enlightened large cities.
I think at the same time
more willingness to
put certain constraints
on other kinds of real estate investment.
For example, in New York it is shameful
that the zillion dollar high rise condos
bought for global investment
that I was talking about,
which sell for amounts of money
several times that of what
had been, a few years ago,
the most expensive apartments in the city,
and that are mainly occupied by people,
mainly bought by people
who don't occupy them.
Somehow, through some loophole,
we're given the right to take advantage
of tax abatement laws that were passed
to encourage the construction
of more affordable housing
by abating them from real estate taxes
for the first 10 or 15
years, whatever it is.
Things like that are a
horrendous embarrassment.
Correcting mistakes like that are good.
There is no easy answer, in part because
we're watching that now in New York
where the new mayor, Mayor De Blasio,
is far more, let's say concerned publicly
about these issues
we've been talking about
than his predecessor was.
His way of dealing with it
is not to discourage
development and growth
but to encourage it and
in effect tax it more.
Not literally tax it, although perhaps so,
but to demand more from
developers in exchange.
In other words saying,
"I don't mind if you want
to build a 100 story condo.
"It's just you're gonna make
100 affordable apartments
"as part of the deal or
you don't build that."
As opposed to his
predecessor who simply said,
"You want to build a 100
story condo? Bravo, hooray,"
and leave it at that.
But that creates in turn
another problem which is that
it may be that good planning
suggests that we be more
limited and more restrictive
on what gets built, period,
no matter who occupies it,
no matter what it is for.
I don't want to solve one
problem and create another.
I don't want us to become indifferent
to matters of physical
planning, historic preservation,
neighborhood stability, and so forth
just because we see in new development
a goose that is laying
some wonderful golden eggs
that we can use for wise and
valuable social purposes.
That's why it's a very, very
complicated thing, I think.
You push in here, and it
pushes up here, and so forth.
It is not an easy thing to deal with.
And as I said before,
even the most socially responsive,
socially activist city government,
is still, at the end of the day,
dealing with global economic
forces that it cannot control
and wants to, to the extent possible,
divert those forces to the
betterment of their city,
as they should.
But they can't turn them on and off.
They can maybe channel them a little bit.
Thank you all very much, again.
- [Dean Wolch] Thank you,
Paul, very much indeed.